okay so venom let the carnage has a
pretty big post credit scene that sets
up a lot of things not only for the sony
verse but also the mcu throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the entire thing and also talking about
how it lines up with the comics what we
think it means for the future and
hopefully answering your questions
before you even ask them god damn he's
fast because of this there will be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't had a chance
to check out the movie then i highly
recommend that you check out now that'll
be carnage if you don't hit the thumbs
up button and make sure you smash
subscribe to stick closer to the channel
than venom does to brock without the way
thank you for clicking this welcome to
the heavy spoilers show now let's get
into venom let there be carnage
okay so info on this scene has been
floating around online for about the
last two weeks earlier in the month a
fan screening was held in london and
though tom hardy told people not to tell
anyone peeps just can't keeps leaks to
themselves now the movie was already
ruined for me when i found out that
eminem hadn't made a song for the
soundtrack called carnage but this scene
is still a pretty big one it's arguably
one of the most important that's ever
been in a marvel movie as not only does
it tease a showdown between venom and
spider-man but it also hints towards how
other franchises will be pulled into the
mcu now in the scene we pick up with
eddie in a hotel room watching a spanish
novella at night after battling it out
with carnage eddie brock has taken
somewhat of a different stance on venom
and he's now fully embracing his role as
the lethal protector venom has always
been somewhat of an anti-hero but it
seems like no matter the universe he's
always gonna have his dark side now the
pair seem to be better than they've ever
been and venom asks eddie if he wants to
see a fraction of what his species has
done little is known about the symbiote
still and this just seems like something
that will be fun for the character well
not fun because because it's enough to
break the multiverse but you know what i
mean anyway the room completely
transforms around them and not only does
it switch from night to day but eddie
actually arrives in a completely
different universe everything is a
slight alteration to the rune that he's
just been in but clearly things have
changed and eddie is now in a completely
different place all of a sudden we hear
the voice of jk simmons as jay jonah
jameson there is a report from the
dailybugle.net which in this universe is
an infowars-esque channel in the
venomverse it's a newspaper but here
it's been changed up to the mcu one jay
jonah is announcing that peter parker
has killed mysterio and it's then that
we realized that venom is now in the mcu
this is very similar to the news report
that was shown at the end of far from
home however there is some additional
footage including a video of spidey with
a mask off standing in what i believe is
new york due to the yellow caps around
him jay jonah also calls spider-man the
spider menace and talks about his web of
lies eh having that we can also catch a
sign that says pen one which i'm
guessing is short for pennsylvania
station if you cast your mind back to
the end of far from home you'll remember
that this is where the news report took
place so potentially spidey unmasked
there and people at the scene blasted it
all over the internet which allowed that
footage to be in this report it's enough
to make even the most hardcore dc head
start smashing the rumor with excitement
and venom licks the screen and makes it
pretty clear that he wants to stick his
tongue down tom holland sorry eat him he
wants to eat the guy now the scene ends
with a guy whose hotel room it is in
this universe walking out and he asks
him who he is and how he got there at
this point venom has turned back into
eddie and he says he doesn't know venom
in the scene denies doing anything so it
is possible that he's either been
brought across by another character
potentially madame webb or venom doesn't
know the true height of his abilities
now eddie's universe wasn't really
filled with superheroes so it's going to
be quite jarring for him to realize that
he's now in a universe full of them
really the man whose room it is doesn't
seem too fast either and this is
probably because his entire home has
been destroyed by the avengers about 50
times he's also dealt with a snap so
yeah it's probably just another monday
am i right however he should be excited
because venom and spider-man are gonna
be in the same movie now this is clearly
something big for the mcu not only does
it cement that characters can now cross
into other universes but it also hints
towards how marvel studios will be
bringing in things like the x-men and
more when disney bought fox they got the
rights to use the characters but outside
of a hilarious boner joke they haven't
really done much with them yet i'll
never forgive you for this fight
never
now during the morbius trailer the
living vampire was seen walking in front
of an image of tobey maguire's
spider-man it's unknown whether he's in
the mcu or not because of this however
he did meet michael keaton's vulture at
the end of the first look so we do know
that at some point he will probably be
coming into the mcu and if he's not
already then this would be a great way
to bring him in now originally in the
comics spider-man first encountered the
symbiote during the events of secret
wars after traveling to an alien planet
he bonded with a creature and this
formed his iconic black suit upon
returning to earth he ran into some
issues that gave him more than a
terrible haircut and some really bad
dance moves the symbiote completely
changed his personality and made him far
more aggressive than he'd ever been
peter was eventually able to free
himself from its control and ended up
bonding with eddie brock before going on
to infect cletus cassidy during a prison
break which allowed him to become
carnage when infinity war was first
announced and we saw the trailers of tom
holland's spider-man in space i thought
that this would be the point at which he
would end up encountering the creature
and that he'd then bring it to earth
that of course didn't happen and at the
time marvel studios were very much about
distancing themselves from sony outside
of their usage of spider-man however
when it looked like the ladder was going
to take back full control of the
character they both came to an agreement
and are now allowing sony owned
characters to interact with their ones
from marvel studios this will of course
allow sony to make a lot more money as
the mcu is pretty much must watch at the
moment and yeah everyone's going to want
to see their films now this is why we
didn't get the classic rivalry from the
comics as the rights issue made sony
basically start their own separate
universe which is now having to be
brought across into this one now with us
being a post-credit stinger the movie
doesn't really have to answer to us
exactly what has happened i actually
think that's someone in sony studios has
probably sat right now on reddit reading
through some of the fan theories like
yes get this in the script for the next
one that's how it explains it i kind of
get the feeling that sony just did it
and said yeah figure it out later much
like when striker's eyes glowed yellow
at the end of days of future past which
yeah still makes no sense now it's
difficult to know exactly when this
scene happens in terms of the mcu
timeline but judging by the news report
it clearly happens before peter and
doctor strange cast the spell in the
trailer this breaks the multiverse wide
open and it allows for characters like
doctor octopus to come across into the
mcu however with this potentially
happening before then it is possible
that it's caused due to the events of
loki which have allowed reality to bend
and shift apart the potential magnitude
of venom showing any things that he's
done might be enough to shift not only
his conscious but also his physical body
into another reality according to
theoretical science if the multiverse
exists then these other universes are
simply on other vibrational frequencies
that we are unable to perceive or
interact with thus venom attempting to
do this has completely altered the way
that eddie perceives reality and it's
allowed him to travel into a brand new
one it's still unsure whether venom will
be in no way home but according to super
duper scuba daniel rpk the character
won't actually meet with spider-man
until venom 3. now where this could be
is because venom is clearly not only in
an unknown country but also an unknown
universe it would be a huge shock to the
system to be transported into another
reality and without a passport or even
knowing anyone from this universe he's
gonna have difficulty getting to new
york i very much feel like no way home
will center around spidey fighting the
sinister six and then we might get venom
showing up in a post-credits scene for
the future it is possible that some of
the symbiote ends up interacting with
peter and then this could create his
black suit eddie could then return home
but venom would now be in the mcu and it
could lead to peter forming a rivalry
against it which would allow it to then
bond with either the mcu's eddie or
return home and be able to shift between
universes personally i'd like to see him
stay in the mcu and possibly even take
on the ancient venom mantle that the
character has in the comics i think his
next film will be about him clashing
with the web head but then he'll see
he's just a good kid and not the
murderer that the reports are making him
out to be it's also impossible to know
whether the memory spell will affect him
or not as he's not from this universe
but if he has landed in the mcu before
that's carried out then he might
genuinely end up forgetting like
everyone else does as mentioned earlier
the madame web movie could also hold the
key and it is possible that she brought
the pear across into the universe once
they reached a certain height of
consciousness and symbiosis together hey
symbiosis are you having that
either way i had a lot of fun with venom
and i think once the film is out
digitally i'll probably do a big
breakdown on all the easter eggs in it
as there's some really cool ones and
lots of things for hardcore marvel heads
in the meantime i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the scene so make sure you
comment below and let me know no doubt
there'll be a lot of theories for this
and what it means for the universe
overall now as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a competition on the 30th
of october in which you could win a
phase three mcu box set we're giving
away three and all you have to do to be
on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the scene we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if that's
you if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of what if episode 8 which
will be linked on screen right now we've
gone over the whole thing and pointed
out all the easter eggs we could find so
definitely go check it out right after
this if not then thank you for sitting
through the video you've been the best
i've been paul and i hope to see on the
next one take care peace